I think Tucker makes a lot of sense for
vice president I've said it publicly
I'll say it privately I
mean I mean I but the case I I kind of
like V I think he's one of those people
who everyone beats up on V for being
he's a phony and all this stuff I don't
know I I've covered a lot of campaigns
going back to 1992 and I've noticed this
thing in many candidates and I noticed
it in him the process the process of
running for president and speaking three
times a day and having people throw
hostile questions in your face causes
you to change they all change during
these campaigns like for real inside and
I feel like V's positions have gotten
much more sincere since the beginning of
this like he I watch him with Nikki Hal
and I'm like this is a guy who's very
offended by her views like for real he's
not attacking her cuz she's a woman he's
attacking her because he actually thinks
her views are terrible for the country
he lives in and I love that mhm so is
that is that a no you're not going to
Tim no I mean it's like the weather I
can't control that I don't think I'd be
that great at it